you've probably heard your favorite
Stars talk about taking the occasional
souvenir from set they ended up making
like 15 of them so there's like just
take one but in the case of Harry Potter
taking things from set was a strict
No-No as spoilers still that didn't stop
the actors from trying Jason Isaacs
watched Alan Rickman slip a few gold
coins into his pockets during the first
days of filming at Gringotts bank which
made him feel like he'd be safe to go up
to director David Yates and politely ask
if he could take home one of the
thousands of copies of the daily Prophet
David said yes but when Jason tried to
leave with the paper he was approached
by a set worker who told him he needed
it back Jason may not have been lucky
but Daniel Radcliffe was able to get
away with two pairs of Harry's glasses
while Emma Watson kept her wand her Time
Turner and a cloak